you tweeted a picture of Amanda Holden
very good friend of mine uh it's a very
harmless picture she's in a bikini on
holiday under a rain shower uh looking
extraordinarily uh beautiful in a sexual
pose and you tweeted you are a wife and
a mother and you're far past a teenager
there's no need for this post agreed
again it's just misogynist to say thaty
what kind a woman of her age she's just
turned 50 what kind a woman of that age
actually show off her beautiful body in
a in a nice bikini like that what's
wrong with that you can call me crazy
you can call me misis but I think once
you reach the ripe age of 50 any woman
should not be interested in verse
trapping on Instagram I think she has
bigger responsibilities I'm sure she's a
very intelligent lady and she's done
amazing things she's famous she's
obviously very capable and I think she
could do things more interesting than
standing around trying to thirst trap on
Instagram like she's 18 I think she's
above it I wasn't insulting her I was
reminding her that she's actually such a
fantastic person she's done such amazing
things in her life and she's so achieved
that she's actually above first traing